it's time to implement the red lines for
the mainactivity we can do one part
together so that you get the hang of it
we begin by styling the list item
forecast layout the red line specifies
that the image should be 32 dips by 32
dip we could hard-code the image view to
be 32 by 32 dips but it's actually the
same as leaving it as wrap content for
height and width to know what the icon
size would be if we wrap content we open
up the mdpi version of the icon and we
do verify that it is 32 pixels by 32
pixels whether we hard-code it or just
set wrap content visually the image will
still look the same but in the future it
will be more flexible if we just specify
wrap content in case the image size
changes next we style the text on Ice
Cream Sandwich and above Roboto is the
default font for text views it was
created specifically to satisfy the
requirements of UI and to optimize for
high density screens the red line
indicates that the font family is Roboto
sans-serif condensed so we add that to
the code on the topic of font sizes
having too many font sizes in your app
can confuse your user about the visual
hierarchy of your app let's see what's
important and what's not important the
Android design guide recommends these
four type sizes for consistency with a
platform and for user experience in our
app we stick to the standard type sizes
unless it's an intentional part of the
design such as the large temperature
values hence when the red lines say that
the date text should be 22 sp4 font size
we could specify Android text size to be
22 SP but the text appearance large
attribute already maps to that value
note that the font sizes are specified
in SP and not dips SP stands for scaled
pixels so you can scale with the device
font size in our app we specify text
appearance large and text appearance
small which will give us 22 SP and 14 SP
respectively the default font color is
black so we don't need to specify the
Android text color attribute on our text
views let's look at the spacing for the
elements within the list item now we
have three children the first one is 60
DP wide with the image centered inside
of it so we can add a frame layout
around the image view and set the
gravity to be Center on the image that
way the image centers itself within the
parent for the other two columns we
shouldn't hard code such high dip values
because otherwise the layout won't scale
across other devices instead we can use
linear layout weights with a weight of 7
here and a weight of 5 we just try
different values until we got
approximately
equal to these values the trick in doing
red lines is that you want to match the
visual specs but you also want to be
flexible in the code so that it adapts
to different screen sizes and this is
what the code looks like for the list
item forecast layout we have our
horizontal linear layout containing the
frame layout with the image view then we
have a vertical linear layout with
weight 7 and then we have another
vertical linear layout with weight 5 you
can check the link below for the full
code file this is what it should look
like when you're done these items look
polished but we haven't gotten to this
today item yet